I think there's definitely a great
chance that China will pull us out of
the economic crisis that we're in love
of the talk last year was about whether
China would be decoupled from the rest
of the world I think that's happened to
a certain extent but I think we'll see
that investment in the Chinese domestic
economy has become so great that it's
putting in a lot of important around the
danger the asia-pacific region and I
think it's a stimulated the economy in
this particular region and it's also
dragging an impossible around the world
so I think the first steps will be an
asia-pacific recovery and then the
recovery will spread to the rest of the
world
you